water of elephants is directed by
Francis Lawrence who made Constantine
and I am Legend and stars Robert
Pattinson Christoph Waltz and Reese
Witherspoon I have a huge crush on Harry
just let you know it was about a guy
whose life pretty much ends I don't want
to really get into much of that for the
most part his life is basically
destroyed he decides to run away and he
hops aboard a train ends up being a
circus train and he gets employed within
the circus throughout various ways he
becomes a veterinarian of the animals
there and he meets and starts to enjoy
the company of Reese Witherspoon's
character who's married to Christoph
Waltz you do not want to mess with
Christoph Waltz's wife it's a bad idea I
don't know if he's getting typecast or
if he's just enjoying the villain roles
so he has kind of a dilemma he's caught
in a huge problem where his employer is
the husband of the woman he's starting
to love in the same time the circus is
struggling a lot there's a lot of
financial problems so there's a lot of
drama to be had in this film and you
know what I enjoyed it one of the things
that's very nice about the film is the
look of the film it's all very
believable the sets are really well done
the costume design is excellent all the
animals look you know very realistic and
there's even some scenes where the more
than likely there's some special effects
use but it looks very convincing I felt
that the three lead actors did nice job
in the roles for the first half of the
film Robert Pattinson could have been a
little more energetic but I think he got
better as the film went on for the most
part he did pretty well I mean I've
never been like a guy who's like
Twilight I'm going to eat everything in
Twilight
I just watch movies that's that's what I
do that's my thing you know and I'm not
gonna add the whole you know tabloid
lifestyle through how I review a film
Reese Witherspoon is you know I I like
her she's a pretty good job in this film
Christa bolts is very effective as the
villain I mean you really hate that guy
you just you wanted to go down there's
some mistreatment of animals in this
film and I love animals whenever I see
that in a movie it always makes me like
enraged it's like one of those moments
where I want to like jump into the movie
and be like are there stewardess you
know what I mean but I felt that the
dramatic scenes were headed well I
thought the romance of the film started
kind of slow where I was like what is
really going on and why is she still
with this husband you know he's just
such a bad person and it's like doesn't
she see I mean she may have had some
fear in regards to that relationship so
that could also explain that it's
started off kind of slow and I was like
where's this going but then eventually
it started to pick up but I was able to
understand why the characters kind of
were very reserved at first I made a
little more sense in my opinion the
movies too long it's about two hours and
I feel I could have been a little bit
shorter it seemed like a drag little bit
at some point towards the end of the
film once certain characters became in
jeopardy and I was really actually
caring I mean I was legitimately caring
for these characters and that's when I
realized I was like you know what this
movie is very effective if you're a
young girl I mean honestly I was talking
with my friend we kind of agreed this is
going to be like the next The Notebook
this gonna be the way we were girls like
Jennifer did you see one for Elephants
oh oh
if I ever see Robert Pattinson I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna make out of them
I'm just gonna kiss him on the face it's
the kind of movie where if you got a
whole bunch of girls in a room and just
went Water for Elephants there would be
like a giant sound I'm not a guy who's
just like this is the chick flick I need
muscles and sweat and action first
target audience excellent job for the
most part it's an enjoyable film it's
just a little too long as some
it says seemed like they could have been
given a little more intensity and it
would have been better I wouldn't give
it three out of four stars girls are
gonna die over this time I mean they're
just going to explode with estrogen